Ronnie over vacation had JD John blitt
and who was the third guy she came to
visit well oh will well what was the
occasion JJ's birthday birthday
yeah how old are you JD I am 43 years
old Jesus how old were you when I met
you
I believe I was 23. wow yeah 20 years of
JD here's what I yeah I got some some
reports if you will yeah Jason will John
blitt
and JD went to celebrate JD's birthday
JD treated himself he upgraded his
flight both ways flying first class on
the way home yeah it was expensive but I
was like you know I'll treat myself once
yeah uh you know so yeah but it cost
about 500 how much he complained about
the food I was like how's how was uh
first class he was like it was
comfortable good to be alone but the
food sucked well the chicken it was girl
chicken it was a little spicy dude what
do you expect it's a [ __ ] flame well
I don't know
Ronnie I was answering the question
that's all I was doing he's expecting
caviar
Lobster John did you bust balls on the
plane at all did you bust JD's balls
what was going on what'd you observe on
the trip thankfully we were on separate
flights both ways so that was a big run
good but you know while in Vegas you
know he's [ __ ] around all the time
we're at the the hotel bar and they're
like eight people next to us and I was
like it was a really lame prank but it
was kind of fun I told them that JD just
graduated law school and when he comes
in for everyone to applaud so it was
like empty bar JD walks it everyone's
applauding yeah here's our new lawyer it
was so
I walk in and all of a sudden all these
people are Applause me I'm like I can
play it completed something what's going
on did something JD this sounds like you
really blew out a lot of dough I heard
uh Ronnie took you to the strip club
and uh you dropped like 600 bucks there
yeah I mean you know I've I was having a
good time it's my birthday you know if
I'm not gonna I'm just having a good
time
um but uh yeah listen they have 100
bucks JD well listen the rules the rules
that some of these strip clubs are
different now rules
are there deals that they have like you
have to have at this one with a Crazy
Horse and they said you have to do like
you can't do table dances uh apparently
for 20 bucks you have to go into a room
three uh three dances for a hundred
dollars and uh and that was that was
pretty much the deal you know how many
you mean there's a minister that's six
dances or how many dances is that I
don't know Robin it's a bit of a blurry
I also told one dancer that JD was a
child star he was the star of karate
baby it was like ever since he was two
and he was making some karate moves yeah
karatebaby.com yeah she looked at me
really yeah
Jason uh now with your new weight with
your new weight loss the women must be
swarming all over you I was kind of
excited you know my wife was like uh
don't don't dance at the club don't you
know just just be cool and I was like I
don't know I have a laugh now and like I
I'd like to actually
with the laugh I have and you take it
for his test
we got Edibles and smoked oh yeah we
went to the pool meet will and and Jason
and we're like where's JD doesn't pick
up he's like well I was in the room just
pacing around for for an hour the gummy
hit him he's just walking around in
circles in the hotel room with the TV on
in the background I wanted the nap I
wanted to try to sleep because I was
tired but I started to feel I took we
went to Planet 13. uh we walked from
there back to the hotel look at gummy
during this walk get back to the hotel
I'm like okay I'm gonna go and take a
nap
I get out to my room then I start to
feel the coming and I'm like oh man I
really don't want to fall asleep and
like I can't wake up like there and I
wake up late for the dinner or something
and I have people bashing on my door
trying to get me up thinking that you
know something's happened so yeah I
basically walked around my room for two
or three hours
[Laughter]
drinking water
but why not go down to the pool if
you're high on the gummy and chill with
the guys yeah it doesn't relax me I
don't know nothing relaxes me I don't
know the stuff that relaxes people does
not relax me so none of this makes any
sense to me you should have just gone to
sleep if you're on the gummy
I was afraid that I wouldn't wake up in
time like I would wake up past I knew we
were on the schedule it would have been
alarm and I'm just afraid to not waking
up in time like I don't want to wake up
late wake up in time for what there was
nothing going on
I wanted to make sure I got there in
time another thing I learned about JD is
that he only checks in his luggage he
will not bring luggage onto the plane oh
it's so annoying we're going for two
days and he was the only one that
checked in luggage you have to stand
there wait for him at the carousel when
we land I wanted to have a like change
of outfits and stuff there was nothing
in this dumb suitcase their Howard oh
shut up he's Celine Dion no it's not
that I wrote special hiking shoes let me
ask something like that so you guys are
the [ __ ] who like you're you're
ready to go and now you're standing
there waiting for JD exactly how many
different outfits you had a night outfit
right you had to go out going outfit
I did I wore what I wore in a plane all
right yeah then I had another outfit for
that night then I had an outfit for
Ronnie's uh then I had a going home
outfit
oh my goodness
you're like a bag that needed to be
checked with three outfits it's a big
bag all right and then I kept saying my
jacket my jacket like a uh my jacket
somewhere
you're like a Kardashian why don't you
call the guys you should have called
Blitz and asked him how he gets
everything into one little bag oh please
what am I gonna listen to him for you
he'll tell me some other [ __ ] like
oh you need to bring 10 outfits
every hour
I'd say don't bring anything I got a
picture of JD in his outfit at Ronnie's
house you want to see it I mean
something special or anything yeah let
me see yeah that's a special it's just
now wow wow it's an outfit yeah very
colorful that definitely needed a neck a
suit all right
how many bags did you take to Southeast
Asia Robin I'm sure you needed some
houses for two weeks all right well okay
I don't know you were there for two days
I don't care
I don't care what if I what if I go to
the what if I go to the strip club and
come in my pants they'll be Brewing
somebody posted a picture of Ronnie's
outfit of the same same night we were
hanging out and Ronnie uh I think promen
got a kick out of Ronnie's outfit for
whatever reason what the [ __ ] Rock Says
Ronnie are you wearing the the jeans
with the two rips in the knees Howard
cut out the knees it was more than and
two reps it was rips I thought his balls
were going to come out on each leg [ __ ]
Mike he said he's a [ __ ] waste did
you rip those or did you buy him like
that dude [ __ ] yourself dude go and [ __ ]
yourself that's a good question
that's legitimate [ __ ] ass with
splinters in it go and [ __ ] yourself
okay how did you get ripped jeans do you
buy them those jeans
when they were new they weren't ripped
like that as I wore them around doing
things I ripped them myself like doing
[ __ ] and I just use them around the
house I don't go out with them okay and
[ __ ] you promise I I think you are the
most aggravated piece of [ __ ] [ __ ]
there is you ripped them like you want
like you were doing yeah you were
purposely ripped them right right right
like you want to be sexy you're so
[ __ ] cool Perlman
it was kind of like a mixture of looks
he had like a ripped pair of jeans like
he was trying to like be like I'm gonna
[ __ ] at you
like he was Kurt Cobain or something
like ripped jeans and then he had like
gone and then he had on like a like a
Montauk shirt over it which kind of
reminded me of like it looks like one of
those shirts that like when you go to a
restaurant you see like an old couple
sitting outside you know if you go
somewhere by the water or something and
it's cold and they always have like a
sweatshirt that usually says something
like um
and they put it on just in case it gets
cold that's what it reminded me of and
then he's also he's got a big can in one
hand then he's got the joint in the
other hand he's holding different stuff
there's just
there's always something that stands out